[Musique]
pour beaucoup la télé réalité rime avec
chirurgie esthétique et ils vous pensiez
que les filles étaient les seuls à en
user vous vous trompez aux fêtes lâchage
esthétique j'en ai fait ouais hier
jordan de luxe recevait le candidat de
dilemme thierry connu pour sa
participation à koh lanta et au prince
de l'amour notamment il a révélé avoir
eu recours plusieurs fois au bistouri
j'ai fait mes facettes ouais j'ai refais
mon nez j'avais une bosse sur le nez
d'accord et je n'ai enlevé mais ce qui a
choqué le plus les internautes c'est le
montant exorbitant qu'il a dû débourser
pour refaire sa plastique et le nez
c'est au moins cinq ou six mille euros
c'est 6000 ouais d'accord ouais donc ne
sera 50 comme quoi certains ne
connaissent pas la crise alors qu'il a
le révèle avoir dépensé environ 50000
euros dans la chirurgie esthétique
voulez-vous c'est un des cent
cinquante mille euros
il est mieux après vous trouverez non
mais le roi est ce que vous trouvez ça
indécent déjà ça et le fait qu'il le
dise ac avant pardon parce que j'ai été
extrêmement mal élevés malpoli on a on
vient d'avoir une invitée qui viennent
avec nous sur le plateau sous le nom de
l'applaudir c'est sylvie
[Applaudissements]
est également esthétique spécialiste de
la vaginoplastie et les fringues du
vagin
d'accord et aussi ma chirurgie
soyez la bienvenue sylvie on va d'abord
jeu d'abord interrogé au maître de mes
petits camarades simplement sur sur
cette histoire de 50000 euros quasiment
cinquante mille euros de ses vestes
éthique et puis c'est un influenceur
donc il le raconte à ce que vous trouvez
que il fait bien de le dire qu'après
tout il n'y a pas de tabou là dessus
benjamin n'y a pas de tabou n'est pas
tabou sur la géorgie après on n'est pas
obligé de donner de mon temps parce
qu'il sait comme beaucoup d'argent 50 kg
après moi j'ai toujours dit la chirurgie
si on se sent mieux après moi je vois
pas d'inconvénient après si ça devient
un stand avec ses influences encore une
fois les jeunes gens les petites filles
kita qui veulent se faire refaire le nez
la poitrine c'est vrai que c'est un
problème maintenant ça fait des années
qu'on se fait refaire les seins et
d'autres comme choses par des amis
sans tabou autour de la table a été voir
un chirurgien esthétique fiona vous avez
fait quoi vous moi j'ai fait la poitrine
très jeune très calme parce qu'elles
n'étaient pas formés à marc et moi je
fais régulièrement et j'ai aucune honte
de dire je fais régulièrement de la
médecine esthétique donc quelques
injections parfois d'accord injection de
code sur le visage de la sibérie running
d'accord à temps là à mon âge et je sais
ce que je veux moi je n'en discute
souvent avec les médecins et je sais que
les gens s'offusquent de ça mais le
médecin me dit et j'ai envie de le
croire ça sert à rien d'attendre que ce
soit marqué ben justement on a suivi
après abba rameute est avec nous vous
êtes donc vous l'avez dit spécialiste
des chirurgies esthétiques et notamment
chirurgie esthétique peut précisément
des parties intimes
vous avez vu madame un top à madame
docteur sais pas c'est pas moi c'est eux
pascal guillaume est très intéressant
guillaume est très intéressant donc
d'abord quels sont les profils de vos
patients qui vient vous voir est-ce
qu'ils sont jeunes comme comme on le dit
parce que influencé par les réseaux
sociaux une esthétique c'est qu'entre
ces deux cents à 77 ans à cette simple
tôt peut-être un si les oreilles
décollées ah oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
et mais nous met donc à ce que je vous
ai pas de chirurgie je fais pas que de
la chirurgie intime heureusement et
surtout pas aux enfants mais bien sûr si
l'on le nord bien sûr rive mais mais
est-ce que vous avez vu et venir une
clientèle une patientèle qu'ils
n'étaient pas venus dans votre cabinet
auparavant parce que parce qu'il y avait
des réseaux sociaux parce qu'il y avait
des influenceurs et c'est elle qui vous
demandent des choses des poitrines des
visages des paysages et depuis des
injections jusqu'au ça en passant par
les liposuccions les paupières etc oui
c'est vrai que j'ai toutes sortes de
demandes et il ya bien il ya
certainement depuis une dizaine d'années
des candidats à ces technologies qui
sont de plus en plus jeunes plus en plus
jeunes oui c'est vrai et être dans ces
cas là justement quand ils sont jeunes
est ce que vous leur dites on patiente
un peu ou es ce que vous avez déjà ya
une règle on peut pas opérer
quelqu'un qui n'est pas majeur sauf s'il
vit avec ses parents mais c'est quand
même rare dans ces cas là et ensuite on
y voit en consultation on teste leur
motivation commenge est une motivation
comment savoir qu'on est juste en disant
on discute pas parce que si c'est un
caprice oui j'ai vu un tel il ya trois
jours à la télé et puis je voudrais
avoir la même chose
est-ce qu'ils viennent avec par exemple
la photo d'un candidat de télé réalité
avec en titane j'arrive à être voilà
avec dylan est ce que je veux être comme
dylan soi même ça ça il y en a qui ont
pu le faire mais qu'on me dise voilà
j'aimerai avoir année dans ce style oui
pourquoi pas mais faire un call ou une
barbie non là on a vu dylan et
annonceurs une somme assez folle en
cinquante mille euros à peu près vous
avez des jeunes patients qui viennent
vous voir et qu'ils dépensent énormément
chez vous c'est con mais c'est quoi une
opération des seins c'est combien par
exemple ce n'est pas en quelle opération
des seins mais disons que pour quelques
milliers d'euros et pas des dizaines de
milliers d'euros et que il ya c'est pas
2003 gambie 5 ça peut être quatre mille
familles ça dépend ce qu'on fait
exactement enfin une en moyenne une
intervention de chirurgie esthétique
c'est le prix d'une petite voiture
d'occasion alors vous en faites vous en
rendez pas compte mais à chaque fois que
vous parlez ya benjamin côté qui aurait
dit connaître par coeur on est tous
pareils on les prie tout illuminé
complètement fermée catherine donc
j'aimerais bien sûr non mais vraiment à
bien sûr que non
j'ai fait des paupières vous avez fait
les paupières mais tellement changé sur
mes petits yeux ouais que j'ai voulu les
aborder bon ça n'a rien changé voilà
donc ça c'est ça va non c'est pas vrai
parce que je trouve comme ça vous va
très bien vous avez à grandir c'est un
jeu est alors typiquement vous l'avez
fait parce qu on parce qu'on vous disait
que c'est vrai j'avais d'ailleurs à la
paupière qui tombait un peu et il paraît
que faire de la chirurgie quand on est
encore pas trop vieux c'est préférable à
ce que les résultats finalement sur le
sur le long terme sera plus plus la
durée des meilleurs alors je peux si
c'est vrai ou pas si oui est ce qu est
ce que ce que dit ben à ce que 10
benjamins et fiona c'est à dire qu'il
faut vous allez dire devancé les
problèmes du temps un livre présentant
ces noms mais il ya un juste moment et
il faut pas non plus tergiverser durant
dix ans quand on a envie de quelque
chose en tout cas j'ai l'impression que
il ya quelques années encore c'était
assez tabou la saison complètement lié
aujourd'hui tout le monde dit moi j'ai
fait un lifting moi c'est toi les
paupières moi j'ai fait mon unique
option cette fois ci mais là c'est le
succès et ses succès chirurgicaux donc
comme on a des résultats qui sont
remarquables et bien ça incite les gens
à se faire opérer il faut quand même tu
voyais les amis on peut quand même dire
que c'est pas anodin de l'an passé sous
le bistouri du chirurgien
mais comme le répéter sur la maladie
s'est pas il faut motiver et c'est pas
sur un coup de tête qu'on fait c'est ça
change encore les amis est ce que vous
trouvez ça et bien de la chaîne en enfer
- c'est très bien mais moi ce que
j'apprécie chez dylan et j'ai plein de
candidats de télé réalité c'est sa
franchise son côté décomplexé et là ya
quand même deux infos c'est un oui j'ai
fait date chirurgie et 2 ça coûte très
cher donc oui je gagne beaucoup d'argent
et j'ai les moyens de me payer leur
attention parce que ils reprirent le
travail demain je n'ai pas regardé ce
qu'il dit c'est jordan de l'ex regard
des éléments peu de hachage esthétique
j'en ai fait ouais vous avez fait les
dents j'ai fait mes facettes way oh oui
bah ouais ou emma avait parlé vous allez
donc vous avez refait quoi d'autre j'ai
refait mon nez j'avais une bosse sur le
nez d'accord et je lui enlever ses tous
d'accord c'est tout c'est tout ça vous a
coûté combien de tours alors tout ça le
nez c'est au moins cinq ou six mille
euros c'est 6000 ouais d'accord ouais
donc descendre à 50 50 mille euros
inchangés ses tics voulait faire quoi
d'autre la question d'un complexe auront
rien même le nez je regrette et nous
avons regretté ouais ouais je les fais
il ya trois ans j'étais jeune j'avais un
petit complexe j'aurais pas dû un homme
ne doit pas toucher son visage ah non
alors il fit rétropédale complètement
énormément donc c'est un peu le
contre-pied de ce que vous dites d'abord
il a dépensé essentiellement dentisterie
mais c'est ça il a pensé à 6000 euros en
chirurgie esthétique deuxièmement il
vous dit exactement ce que je vous ai
raconté tout à l'heure elle sa voix
j'étais trop jeune je les fais genre
direct et oui effectivement il est trop
jeune il l'a fait sur un coup de maître
pardonnez-moi pardonnez-moi sylvie mai
et la plupart du temps quand on va voir
un chirurgien il ya rarement chirurgien
qui vous dit vous savez quoi moi c'est
non chez moi allez voir un confrère
parce qu on dit réfléchissez monde
annonce jean sait vraiment quand je les
vois on va en parler moi pour mon
expérience personnelle moi je suis le
premier chirurgien j'avais 17 ans parce
que j'ai portée je vais vous raconter
rapidement j'ai porter un corset pendant
trois ans est vraiment à votre ma
poitrine ne s'est pas développée et a 17
ans quand je suis à voir le chirurgien
jeudi par mois c'est un vrai complexe
mais vraiment un vrai complexe il m'a
dit non déjà on va attendre que vous
soyez majeur et en plus de ça on va
attendre juste votre temps de réflexion
parce que vous êtes jeune forcément
envie de le faire très rapidement mais
non on va prendre les précautions
nécessaires et je les fais au nom après
donc que j'avais eu un an de réflexion
et je regrette pas mais ça change un
corps il faut vraiment réfléchir gilles
je reviens à votre question de base qui
est indécent c'est la somme que la
sauvegarde et 1000 euros
30 fois le smic et la parcourir des
familles
étaient
choquants il fait ce qu'il veut de son
animateur messager pour dylan mais on se
fait par faire les facettes pour 40
millions
qui le délire est totalement éteint
déclenché tout ça bien il est jeune et
il assume
c'est en plus c'est un témoignage monde
même si on regrette donc je trouve ça
formidable or isabelle le tournoi
toujours eu un côté super vantard sur
l'argent comme moi je trouve assez
pesant à la longue quand il dit je gagne
100 mille euros par mois donc
effectivement 47 mille euros faut pas
trop oui voilà pour lui mais il a
toujours parlé de strict ce garçon parle
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent et nous les moyens on avait
engagé son pognon et festive
à côté pendant mes aux défavorisés et à
côté on s'intéresse à merveille - pardon
mais ces gens là ne prennent pas les
gens pour des cons j'en ai marre de voir
des célébrités d'hier je gagne 3000
euros je gagne 4000 euros alors qu'il
vienne dix vingt trente fois plus et là
où on dit que les gens qui font la
promotion de la chirurgie esthétique
créer des complexes et les jeunes c'est
tout l'inversé quand on voyait des stars
dans les magazines et qu'on ne savait
pas qu'elle était refaite en dise ah bah
je suis pas aussi belle que les actions
locales la revoir et voilà il est beau
mais on sait qu'il est refait donc c'est
complètement assumé c'est très bien de
le dire c'est une preuve de victoire à
dax allemand on n'arrête pas de dire que
c'est eux qui complexent les jeunes dont
vous dites que finalement il est
complexe mais non ils les décomplexe
femme il l'aurait da comprends ils les
aident à comprendre que ce que c'est
faux en fait trop il est fils de vérité
sont par ailleurs les rebelles ont une
belle plastique mais c'est du faux gras
dits l'assumer alors non seulement
c'était enfin tu as tort encore une fois
parce qu'il est complexe alors on va le
dire gentiment
par exemple il faut pas exagérer mais en
fait la télé réalité pour moi parce
qu'il est quand même ici de la
téléralité la forme at complètement les
corps et les visages ouais et donc on
veut absolument que la leur il faisait
koh lanta maintenance et les princes de
la mouvance et latvala est en fait
évidemment fiona dans ton cas c'est pas
du tout pareil que moi pour moi dans ton
cas et on a très très bien à paris c'est
presque de la chirurgie réparatrice vous
est alors persuadé ses parents mais sait
pas pourquoi leur semblait annabi nam
hai ba voilà alors qu'aujourd'hui les
nénettes télé réalité elle regarde enfin
les jeunes téléspectatrices regard mais
personne de télé réalité et elle dit moi
je veux ressembler à untel ou à untel
pour pouvoir être après célèbres comme
dylan et pour pouvoir après gagné 46
mille euros pour pouvoir me refaire les
dents ou le nez donc c'est complètement
destructeur et c'est catastrophique et
on fait des futures générations de
névrosés sa main ce que jamais dans le
cinéma par exemple et américains depuis
50 ans toutes les actrices médailles
sont exceptionnels non mais non mais non
seulement cela ils font appel à la
chirurgie mais en plus quand elles
veulent avoir un rôle il ya des
producteurs qui leur demande de refaire
des parties de leur corps pour
le cinéma il ya voilà c'était avant
parce qu'il ya de bonnes plus en plus de
réalisateurs qui disent je la rendrai
plus tard chez les sujets
jeunes comme si peu se ralentir à cause
de ça mais un exemple à la crise qui a
fait quelque king kong alors épauler le
rôle s'est pas refait sa poitrine donc
ces instants
mais maintenant on en passe c'est
totalement décomplexée mais ça fait des
années que plein de the stars de la télé
du cinéma
c'est pas normal dans une injonction à
noah a offert son nez ça donc à
raison pour une fois c'est que au moins
maintenant on sait qu effectivement le
résultat que l'on voit à l'écran ou dans
sa télévision ou au cinéma n'est pas
forcément résultats naturels ces 12 qui
dit il n'a pas complètement tort